we are 24 hours away from that historic
kickoff in las vegas over 60 thousand
people we'll see the hometown raiders
try to stop one of the most talented
quarterbacks in the game john treach is
here now with our sunday preview john
yeah john gruden has drawn a lot of
plays in his three decades in the nfl
but some guys defy scheme deter defense
and demand an explanation for their
supernatural abilities gruden says the
ravens lamar jackson is that kind of
problem grew to admits you can well
spend six weeks of training camp doing
coaching calculus and defensive work
workshops but to
try and stop this ravens mvb quarterback
it ultimately may come down to him just
being too fast to tackle and too
talented to contain it's what makes this
sunday so sleepless but also worthy of a
week one challenge
my summer project was i got every one of
lamar jackson's lamar jackson's runs
and i put him on a reel i think it was
374 plays and then we put him together
by play what kind of play was he getting
the ball on a lot of plays were
scrambles there are drop back passes
where he just takes off
he's that like that dodge ball movie he
can dip and duck and i don't remember
the other ds but he can go crazy back
there
this guy's a you know he's worth the
price of admission it'll be fun to watch
our guys chase them i know our guys are
ready to give their best effort
dodge duck dive dip and dodge it's been
a dizzing day of nfl football there have
been tributes and touchdowns and so many
surprises that's what makes the las
vegas show tomorrow so different than
all the others in town anything can
happen